Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
If you are watching this video that means that I have had a baby.
Birthed through the sweat of my brow and the effort of my epic loins.
What's that? .... Sarah did the birthing?
Well, what was my role then?
Oh. Apparently Hank, I told her, to push.
*Singing* 'Real American heroes, telling their partners when to push'
Although actually, the doctor gives the instructions, and..I just kinda reinforce it so...
Yeah, I'm not really the hero of this story, Hank.
Also, I just turned the birth of my baby into a beer commercial. Right!
So Sarah actually had the baby, but I'm gonna help with diaper changes and many other tasks.
Hank, when Henry was born, I only took a couple weeks off.
In fact, I went on my first work trip when he was nine days old.
This time I'm going to take quite a bit more time away.
Not just from Vlogbrothers, but also from writing, and travelling, and from my career as an -
- amateur historian, trivia buff and of course most importantly; semi professional Fifa player.
However Hank, in this absence, I will be exceedingly present.
For instance, there will be a 'Crash Course' US History video every single Thursday.
And, a 'mental_floss' video every Wednesday.
And the Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers will play every Monday, Wednesday and Friday,
as they continue their heroic domination of League 1.
This is possible because everyone in the office has worked extremely hard to get way ahead for the baby.
So thank you to Stan and Mark and Danica and Meredith for being awesome.
Okay Hank, there are links to all these things on screen and in the video info below.
So really, I will not be leaving you at all.
Past me will just be visiting present you, with essentially the same story as 'Back to the Future 3'.
Also every Tuesday, there will be a John video, just like always on this very YouTube Chanel.
Except usually, where the role of John is played by me.  It'll be played by other people like: Hannah Hart, and Grace Helbig, and Craig Wheezywaiter.
Which is his real last name, and my secret sister; Maureen Johnson.
Not to mention, two Nerdfactor winners.
And now Hank, a quick visit from future me to current you to give you a baby update.
Hi, everything is good. Baby and mother are healthy, and beautiful and wonderful, and we're exhausted and hi.
Alright Hank, current me is going to make a prediction about future me; That guys looks tired! I'm a psychic.
Nerdfighters, thank you as always for making this community exist and for making it such a wonderful part of my life.
And also for letting me briefly step away to be a full time dad.
DFTBA, Hank, I will see you on Friday.